so listen I have a ton of questions
about rings of power loved your work on
it but I definitely have to start with
uh how did Battlestar change your life
because that's where I first like heard
your music and became a fan Battlestar
Galactica was my first job
as a composer
um to say that it changed my life is the
understatement of the century
um realistically speaking no one should
let a 24 year old child score their big
budget uh reimagining of a sci-fi
classic and uh it was a combination of
luck and hard work and diligence and uh
that I that I that I survived that
Gauntlet and I did one episode
which happened to be 33. I worked on the
mini series but then I happened to do
episode one from season one and then
they let me do another episode
and let me do another episode and there
it was I mean it it
was fascinating because to me Battlestar
gave me half of the pieces that I needed
to do a show like rings of power
um it it forced me to learn so many
modern techniques not only about
production and samples and producing a
score in the 21st century but
storytelling I mean Battlestar was it
doesn't sound it now
but then that was not how you scored
sci-fi space operas on TV it was a very
modern approach
but the other half of my personality the
other half of my skill set is a much
more traditional one I studied under
Elmer Bernstein I studied another guy
who wrote the Ten Commandments man he he
scored Ghostbusters it's on your shirt
so he taught me the absolute
fundamentals of dramatic storytelling an
orchestral writing and filmmaking and
how to talk with a filmmaker so you take
that skill set that very old school
skill set
suddenly I'm throwing in a Battle Star
Galactica I'm learning all these modern
things and though there was a lot of
orchestral writing
not really kind of a good school score
it was a very modern score at the time
but you can see how to do the rings of
power on a television schedule
in the modern era it really took both of
those
sides of my personality and my
experience to do that and I you know
Battlestar was everything to me man it
opened doors it it taught me how to find
my own voice as an artist
um and it it made my name something that
people were aware of much earlier in my
career than than it would have otherwise
so I'm very grateful to everybody at
that show for taking a chance on me
because boy did they take a chance on me
no 100
um with rings of power this is one of
those did you actually debate it all
um taking the job because of how many
fans like you know what I mean like
there's so many fans that have gonna
have feelings either way or were you
sort of like this is I'm doing this this
is no
Steve I was all in the minute it was
announced I was like the minute it was
announced I thought
I have to do this I I have to do this
and uh it's funny because only later
in press interviews when people asked
well what did you do what about the
pressure of following Howard Shore that
I thought
oh yeah that was there but I was so
excited
to be able to tell part of Tolkien
legendarium you know to be a part of
this story coming to screen I was so
excited to do that that it it the
pressure part of it never really
occurred to me
um because if you think about it right
if if my brain were even wired to think
that way
then I couldn't even get out of bed and
come into the studio I mean you can't
get out of bed and say write a piece of
music that's going to be as good as the
Shire theme I mean dude you can't
so it really wasn't even I think I
accidentally
put blinders on and just thought I'm
gonna dive in and let's who's Nori I'm
gonna write a theme for this character
who's Galadriel like let's let's figure
this out let me let me write something
for her
so in a way
my naivete helps me not to go back to
Battle Star but I mean Battlestar I was
24 and it's like oh you can do one
episode
all right well if you think about it
like if I if I succeed I can have a
career and if I fail it's over I can't
be creative in that environment I I was
just grateful to have a story to tell
that inspired me and have some skill set
that I have honed to think let me use
those skills and tell this story like
I'm so lucky it's gratitude man it's
gratitude is what I felt more than
anything else
um did you have do you have a favorite
uh theme or scene from season one that
you're especially proud of that if
someone hasn't seen the show that that's
the piece of music they should seek out
first no it's very hard to say there are
so many that I'm
delighted by I I love coming into
numenor in 103 coming into Kaza Doom in
in 102 I feel like those were places
where I get to make a good statement and
say
welcome to this version of Middle Earth
um with that said those are not really
favorite moments my favorite moments are
much more subtle they're they're
character moments
when elrond
in um
fourth episode four or five somewhere in
there he comes up to uh Doran who's mad
at his father and he just says hey you
think you have a bad like you know my
dad was a star
you know and he has this moment of
bonding with him and it's just this
de-escalation of tension and you love
these two characters and I get to use
both their themes
moments like that really shine but if I
had to pick one it might be the end of
the first episode where Galadriel makes
a decision about whether or not she's
going to go to valinor
and she like looks in the lens
and it's one of these moments that is so
lyrical and operatic that it that
without the music it wouldn't work
um
because you you have to feel emotions so
intense
um and it's such poetic beautiful
imagery that might be the one yeah
that's where I thought you know
I've introduced this theme for her early
in the episode and and I get to pay it
off in this beautiful bookend that that
first episode
I'm curious I've spoken to a lot of
composers uh how are you writing music
to the script or do you sort of uh wait
till you have footage like talk a little
bit about your writing process my mentor
was Elmer Bernstein as I already
mentioned and he used to watch a movie a
dozen times and he would say the movie
tells you what it needs
I I am like that uh scripts are great I
understand structure and intention
um but to start writing only from a
script bypasses the contributions of
actors
fighting the DP the editors the effects
the production design costumes they all
influence where my brain goes so I have
to see it I'm a very visual person
um and often if I write from a script
I'll I'll end up going the wrong
direction because all those other people
add add to it
um
it's a little different with rings of
power because I I feel like I knew that
I pee so well I was tempted to start but
even then I didn't start until they sent
me
um episodes I could look at uh I
definitely have to ask you uh about
season two and if you have already
started composing I have that's about
all I can say at the moment but it's
gonna be awesome yeah I'm confident
they're not going to screw this thing up
you know but how long did you how long
did you actually spend doing music for
season one and was it something that you
were just focused on or were you also
looking at other projects at the same
time yeah I I was able to shuffle my
deck to focus fully on this and in fact
uh you know I've been quite open as I
talk about
I have a support staff that helps me do
TV it's the way you make TV uh scores in
the 21st century but I wrote Every queue
in the rings of power I I shuffled the
deck so that they would help me on
everything else
um because I really wanted to craft
something where every moment was
completely bespoke to the themes to the
characters
um
it was a challenge I'm not gonna lie I I
think because of covid uh disrupting
production schedule the composer got
hired real late on the rings of power so
I got hired
and I had nine months to write nine
hours
um so I got hired and I started right
away and I did an hour a month and so in
that nine months I was in this studio
writing
anywhere from 12 to 15 hours a day every
day and I took no more than
seven or maybe 10 days off took a few
days off for Christmas holiday
Thanksgiving day but that's it man I
mean that was it and and the toll on my
mind on my body
um on my muscles it was intense it it
there's a reason that people don't write
nine hours of Music in in nine months
um and uh I mean you know
uh if that was a feature film or a
series of films like that would be years
you could do that over years
um so that was a that was a that was a
marathon but like I said I feel like I
was uniquely positioned all my years
studying with Elmer and just studying
classic film
and yet what was the majority of my
experience has been television I started
in Battlestar we did 20 episodes a year
in Battlestar
um so in a way like I was uniquely
positioned to be able to just run that
marathon and and survive it and I'm
proud of it you know I mean I'm I'm I I
think the score
benefited from that kind of total almost
mono maniacal Focus that I gave it yeah
listen man I thought you did a great job
with the score and uh I'm already
looking forward to hearing whatever you
come up with for season two on that note
I need to stop I'm just gonna say I
really am a big fan of your work and
thank you for what you do uh thanks uh
really great speaking with you Steve